a very warm welcome to all viewers
it is crazer from simply learn and in
this video
we will be looking at the uipath
orchestrator
as you might already know uipath studio
is a software application
that assists developers by automating
the creation of robots
unlike the ui path studio the uipath
orchestrator
is a robot entity represented by the
uipath robot's image
and controls its capabilities if you
want to know about uipath then you can
check out our ui path tutorial
let's look at today's plan
we will first see what is uipath
orchestrator
then we will look at the orchestrator
capabilities as to what things the
orchestrator is responsible for
post that we will see the use cases of
the orchestrator
and then we shall see the orchestrator
user interface
and understand the different components
present in it
finally we will look at the hands-on
demo
but before we begin if you love watching
tech videos
then subscribe to our youtube channel
and make sure you press the bell icon to
never miss an update
what is ui path orchestrator
ui path orchestrator is a web
application
that allows you to orchestrate the
execution of repetitive business process
by ui path robots orchestrator
manages the creation monitoring
scheduling
and controlling of automated bots and
process
it serves as a point of integration for
third-party solutions and applications
it's a centralized forum for managing
and controlling
all software boards it can manage the
entire robot fleet let's look at the
orchestrated capabilities
provisioning provisioning establishes
and maintains the connection between the
robots and the web application
deployment deployment ensures that the
correct package versions are delivered
to the assigned robots for execution
configuration configuration looks after
the maintenance and delivery of the
robot environments and process
configuration
queues queues ensures that the workload
is distributed automatically across
robots monitoring monitoring manages
user permissions and keeps track of
robot recognition details
logging logging logs are stored and
indexed in a sql database
interconnectivity interconnectivity
functions as a centralized contact point
for third-party solutions or
applications
let's look at the orchestrator use cases
the strength of uipath orchestrator
comes from its ability to control the
entire robot fleet
let's look at the different use cases
the first is attended this type of robot
is activated by user events
and operates at the same workstation as
a human
orchestrator is used with attended
robots to provide a centralized process
deployment
and logging medium unattended
in virtual environments robots can run
unattended and automate a variety of
process
the orchestrator is in charge of remote
execution
control scheduling and support for work
use in addition to the attended robot
capabilities
studio or studio x they have unattended
robot capabilities
but it should only be used to connect
your studio or studio x
to the orchestrator for creation
purposes
non-production robots are similar to
unattended robots
but they can only be used for research
and development
attended unattended non-production
studio
and studio x robots can all be operated
from a single location
let's look at the orchestrator user
interface
dashboard enables us to see charts and
statistics
illustrating usage information for all
the orchestrator components like
process assets queues schedules
robots jobs and transactions
let's look at the tenant context to view
and control the tenant level entities in
your orchestrator
pick tenant from the sidebar menu with
only one instance of the orchestrator
multi-tenancy allows you to isolate data
these features help you to automate
various departments within your
organization
while also ensuring that orchestrated
data is approved according to your
preferences
please bear in mind that all of the
information is contained in the same
database
let's look at the components one by one
robots a robot is an execution host
that runs ui pass studio process you can
add robots
edit them display the status and license
state
adjust the environment they are assigned
to and change the runtime settings on
the robots tab
you can also see the logs that a single
robot has created
process can be downloaded and executed
automatically by robots using custom
settings
while building or editing a robot you
can configure automatic process
downloading
logging level font smoothing and
resolution in the settings tab
folders folders give you a
fine grain control over automation and
their associated organizations
as well as staff through the entire
organization
in the orchestrator there are two types
of folders
classic and modern classic folders
functionality is allowed by default
while modern folders functionality must
be enabled by the host or the tenant
administrator
users a user is an individual with
access dependent capabilities
whose view and control of the
orchestrator are determined by the
access rights granted
users can be developed and managed
either locally in the orchestrator
or an external directory
roles in orchestrator the roles tab
help you to handle user permissions the
orchestrator view
that a consumer has is defined by the
role they have been assigned
a function allows you to control view
edit
create and delete permissions on all
orchestrator pages and modules
machines a machine page allows you to
provision
and control machines in preparation for
registering robots
with the orchestrator it lists all of
the machines that are currently in
operation
as well as their forms it allows you to
create your computer whether it's
standard or a template
packages all projects published from ui
patch studio
and those manually imported are
displayed on the packages tab
you can display all available versions
of any package on the packages tab
as well as the status claims and release
notes
if they are available ml skills
ml skills retrieves and requests machine
learning skills
from the ai fabric service it
authenticates the robot that is running
the
machine learning skills audit
the audit page shows the audit trail for
all
acts taken by orchestrator entities
several criteria including component
user
action and time can be used to filter
the data on the audit page
credential stores a credential store
is named location inside a safe store
such as cyberark
where you can get robot credentials and
credential assets when you need them
at the tenant stage orchestrator
encourages the users of several
credential stores
webhooks webhooks make it easier to
integrate your uipath automation
with the rest of your app ecosystem
you can subscribe to the orchestrator
events and have them sent to the
external dcm
bpm or crm solutions to notify various
users about the new queue
items that can be processed cause
failures or process updates
license robot licensing is available
both at the host and the tenant level in
the orchestrator on the license list
this enables you to shorten your
deployment time and handle activation
from a single location
within a single click you can trigger
renew
delete and delegate licenses
alerts notifications for robots
queue objects triggers tasks procedures
and activities are shown on the alerts
tab
you will receive updates from all of
your folders on this tab
and you will not be able to choose more
granular options
alerts are sent in real time and can be
categorized as
info success warn error or fatal
settings you can adjust various settings
on the settings tab
including the time zone email warning
information
account information package feeds and
interactive authentication
now let us look with respect to the
folder context
from the sidebar menu pick any available
folder
to view and control the entities within
that folder
automations contains the following tabs
process jobs triggers and locks
the process page allows you to build new
process from uploaded packages
manage existing process and keep all of
your process up to date with the latest
package versions
this allows you to spread packages
through the entire organization
users and robots and execute process
more quickly from the jobs task
jobs on a uipath robot a job represents
the execution of a procedure the
execution of a job
can be started in either attended or
unattended mode
on attended robots you can't run a job
from the orchestrator
and they can't run under a locked
computer
triggers triggers allow you to run jobs
in a predefined sequence at
predetermined intervals and if a new
products are added to your queues
logs the locks page shows you all of the
robot logs
in all of the folders you have access to
to access the locks tab you must have
view permission on the locks
locks are kept in the local database if
the orchestrator is in accessible
monitoring
monitoring contains the following tabs
machines
process queues and sla
machines displays information about all
the existing run times
on an aggregate basis and allows you to
check the overall health
of each run type process the process
page allows you to build new process
from the uploaded packages
managing existing process and keep all
of your process
up to date queues a queue is a storage
container that can accommodate an
infinite number of objects
multiple types of data such as invoice
information or customer information
may be stored in queue objects other
systems such as sap
or salesforce can be used to process
this data
by default the data stored in and output
from the queue items is in free form
sla displays sla and risk sla
information
for all queues in the current folder
with sla predictions allowed
this allows you to determine if the
newly added queue items
will be processed on time and if so what
resources you will need to devote to
ensure that their sla is not violated
when the sla is in danger of not being
reached you will be
adequately informed so that you can make
the required changes
queues use contains the following tabs
queues and review request
in the queues pages click on the review
request tab
to show revision request the page shows
items in different queues that have been
allocated for revision
assets assets are usually shared
variables or credentials
that can be used through several
automation projects
they allow you to store unique
information that the robots can easily
access
storage buckets rpa developers may use
storage buckets to provide a per folder
storage solution
when building automation projects the
storage buckets page
shows you your current bucket
configuration and allows you to build as
many new storage buckets as you need
testing
testing contains the following tabs test
sets
test cases test execution test schedules
and test data queues
test set a test set is a collection of
any number of individual test cases
each intended to serve a specific
function
the test sets page list of few currently
available test sets and allows you to
build new tests
updating existing ones and run them
test cases the test cases page shows all
of your test cases
from all of your projects and app
versions in one place
these are the test cases that are used
in and to make up your test sets
test executions your previously executed
test sets and their information
are shown on the test execution tab
since
test sets are often subject to change
test executions
act as an immutable record of any given
test sets execution at a given point in
time
test schedules allow you to run test at
predetermined intervals and in a
scheduled manner
test data queues using test data queues
you can store and manage your test data
the test data queue
serves as a container for queue items
that are ready to be consumed via
various activities
the test data queue items are uploaded
or deleted based on the first in first
out concept
action catalogs task catalogs are task
containers
that allow you to categorize your task
using a variety of criteria
the catalog where a task is stored is
defined when the task is created using
studio's build type task operation
in orchestrator the catalog must be
specified first
if you mention a catalog that has not
been generated in the orchestrator
the task is created in orchestrator
without a catalog
settings setting contains two tabs
permissions and machine permission a
user
is an individual with access dependent
capabilities
whose view and control of the
orchestrator are determined by the roles
assigned to them
users may be installed locally in the
orchestrator or an external directory
machines you can use the machines page
to provision
and manage system entities which you can
then use to bind uipath robots to the
orchestrator
it lists all of the machines that are
currently in use
as well as the types machines are global
tools
which means they can be accessed from
any folder
let's look at the demo in this demo we
will see
how to connect ui path robot with the
orchestrator
how to run workflow using the
orchestrator
let's go to the browser in the browser
enter
platform.uipart.com
this will take you to the uipath.com
website
if you have already an account sign in
enter the password
click on sign meanwhile
open the ui path assistant so this is
the ui path assistant
so uipath robot is a kind of
representative which runs the workflow
so we create a workflow in the uipath
studio then we upload it on the cloud
orchestrator
then we configure different robots to
run this workflow
now that we have logged in to the
orchestrator
go to the admin
so you need to click here to add tenant
for the
ui path community free edition you can
add only one tenant
so i have already created a tenant so
this
option is disabled for me so when you
click
on the internet for the first type the
tenant window will be displayed
then fill the tenant name password and
confirm the password
and it will ask you for name surname and
email address which is optional
so after filling the details click on
provision the tenant and tenant admin
are created and displayed in the tenants
page
so as you can see the tenant is created
there is an option here users and groups
you can go to the users
and you can see the different users so
this is my user
this is me now you can go to the groups
and see the different groups allocated
and their licenses
so now that we have created a tenant
i have named it an entire segment let's
open it
meanwhile you can open ui path assistant
open ui path assistant this is the ui
path robot
there are two different ways to connect
robot to the orchestrator
one is signing in the uipath assistant
it will take the token from the ui path
orchestrator
by user authentication and it will
directly connect machine and the robot
and the other way is to manually connect
so we'll
sign in
enter the password
now you can see here robot is connected
to the orchestrator
so when you sign in the robot will get
connected to the orchestrator
you can go here in the preferences
go to the orchestrator settings and you
can see connected and licensed
so let's go to the orchestrator
in the orchestrator go to the tenant
context
and here you can see the robot is
connected
it's enabled if you go to the machines
you can see the machine is also
connected
so you can see here
there is an unattended robot here
so to get this unattended robot what you
have to do is
go to the users
select the user which you are using this
is my username
go to edit
and here you should enable this
unattended robot enable this option
and enter the username to get the
username you can open the command prompt
and enter who am i so you will get the
username copy paste the username
enter the password and click on update
and the unattended robot will get
created
so that is how you create the unattended
robot
now that we have connected robot to the
orchestrator
let's open the ui patch studio we'll
create a workflow
and then we'll run it using the robot
so now we have opened the uipath studio
let's open a blank process
after opening the uipath studio click on
open main workflow
first we'll drag and drop a sequence
then we need a input dialog box we'll
drag and drop input dialog box
enter our title let's say we'll enter it
as
ui path orchestrator
enter the input label we'll enter it as
enter your name
let the input type b as text box let's
create a variable say we'll name it as
name and let the variable type be string
and the scope is in the sql scope
we have created the variable so the
value entered should be
the variable view
now we'll drag and drop message box
from this set should be displayed
so you enter a caption for the message
say bait
welcome
and enter the text let's say
hi
and we need to concatenate it with the
variable names
will say thanks for watching
this video
so here we go we have created a workflow
now we need to publish this in the
orchestrator
so you can see an option here called
publish click on the publish button
so you can see the package name the
version
the new version and all the other things
click on the publish button
so the workflow is successfully
published so
the name is blank process 3 and version
is 1.0.60
so let's go to the orchestrator
in orchestrator go to the my workflow
folder context in this go to my packages
if you go here you can see refresh it
so here you can see blank process three
so process
what we did now it was published three
minutes ago
let's go to the process and the version
what we published was 1.0.16
so the name was blank process 3.
let's start the job you can
change the job priority we'll keep it as
normal the other things is default the
process name and the job type
let's let's execute this process one
time click on start
as you can see command send for blank
process 3
so here you can see it is getting run
here you can see it is asking for uipath
orchestrator what we entered the title
and enter your name
let's enter some name say sam
will click ok so hi sam thanks for
watching
this video there you go the message has
been displayed
like normally in ui patch studio we
click on the run button and run the
workflow
but here we have published it in the
orchestrator
and through the orchestrator through the
robot we are
running it and the message is displayed
i hope you liked the video
thanks for watching this video please
don't forget to like share and subscribe
to our channel
thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here